I would start Dennis Schroeder in the
third quarter I'm not going to allow
Jamal Murray to establish a rhythm as we
take a look at Scott Foster
the Foster going to get that attended to
during the playoffs the official
officials is always an alternate in the
arena
I have to say I've never seen a game
stop for a 30-second violation as LeBron
hits Scott Foster right there
that's a big man running into you
Foster in his 29th year he's been an NBA
Finals official for a long time
I'll tell you though you could look at
some guys and you can see quit in the
eyes Scott Foster looks like he's going
to be around the rest of the way
let's bring in Steve jabby for a moment
hey Steve I'm sure in your career you
have times where you got hurt during the
course how do you how do the officials
handle this I don't know I'm just
sitting here looking at Scott and saying
Stitch him up and put him back in let's
go this is the playoffs you know now
I've gotten run over a few times there's
no doubt these guys are big out there
you try to get out of the way and
sometimes it's just too you know they're
just too quick and you can't connect
this situation right there everybody say
Scott's just getting hit and I know his
whistle was in his mouth so he'd
probably cut himself on his lip there
you can see but he's a tough guy he's
staying in all right Steve surprises
doesn't happen more often quite honestly
I got a feeling you'd be in the back
right now with the replacement filling
in
Mitchell Irvin warm it up
Mitchell Irvin is back in the locker
room he's the alternate official